And I want to invite all of us to please turn together to the book of Ephesians.
So if you've not been here before, we've been going through the book of Ephesians in the New Testament.
And in the book of Ephesians, we see what it means to be in Christ and to find our identity together in him.
And over the past couple of weeks, we've seen that in Christ we can have a new life.
We've been given a new self.
And that new self is characterized by true likeness and holiness because it is created in the image of God.
It is the very likeness of Christ that has been given to us.
We are clothed in the righteousness of Jesus.
This is the new self.
We're also seeing now that there's a new way of life that corresponds with that new self.
So we've been made new in Christ.
What does that look like in practice?
And that's what our text is going to show us today.
So let's read Ephesians chapter four and we're going to begin in verse 25 and read down into chapter five, verses one and two.
It says, Therefore having put away falsehood,
Let each one of you speak the truth with his neighbor, for we are members of one another.
Be angry and do not sin.
Do not let the sun go down on your anger and give no opportunity to the devil.
Let the thief no longer steal, but rather let him labor, doing honest work with his own hands,
so that he may have something to share with anyone in need.
Let no corrupting talk come out of your mouths, but only such as is good for building up as fits the occasion,
that it may give grace to those who hear.
And do not grieve the Holy Spirit of God by whom you were sealed for the day of redemption.
Let all bitterness and wrath and anger and clamor and slander be put away from you, along with all malice.
Be kind to one another, tenderhearted, forgiving one another as God and Christ forgave you.
Therefore be imitators of God as beloved children and walk in love as Christ loved us
and gave himself up for us as a fragrant offering and sacrifice to God.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together, shall we?
Lord, we want to pray now what we've just sung.
Speak, oh Lord, as we come to you.
Lord, I pray that as we open your word together, that we would receive it as from you.
I pray that your spirit would open our eyes to see more of Jesus.
And Lord, as we see more of him, Lord, I pray that we would also see even ourselves more clearly.
Lord, as we see him and see ourselves, that it would cause us not to shy away,
but Lord, to run to Christ and to know the grace and mercy and life that are found in him.
We pray all of this in his name, amen.
Well, if you were to look up a list of the greatest artists of all time,
there'd be a few names that would pop up on pretty much every list,
but one of them would certainly be Michelangelo.
Now, Michelangelo, so not the Ninja Turtle in case anybody was curious,
Michelangelo was this great artist and he did paintings.
He was involved in architecture.
He also wrote poetry, but his favorite art form and probably his most lasting legacy was his sculptures.
And probably his most famous sculpture is David.
And over a million people still go to see that sculpture every single year.
But he once said something that gave insight as to how he approached his work as a sculptor.
And it stuck with me.
Now, let's know what he said.
He said, every block of stone has a statue inside it.
And it is the task of the sculptor to discover it.
And then he says, I saw the angel in the marble and carved until I set him free.
So from his perspective, as he's looking at the marble, as he's looking at the stone,
the statue is already there.
And it's his job to chip away at it and get in there and find that statue to kind of draw out what is already there.
And like the sculptures trapped in the marble, what we're seeing about the new self is that it is already there.
If you have put off the old self and put on the new self, you have already been recreated in the image of God.
You've been given the righteousness and holiness of Jesus.
And yet that likeness must be brought out.
It takes a lifetime of sculpting for that to be seen.
So to put this in theological terms, sometimes this is referred to like those two things being true at the same time as
positional sanctification and progressive sanctification.
So hold that thought with me for a second.
So positional sanctification says this is your position.
Like you are in Christ, you are already sanctified, you are already set apart when God sees you,
he sees you in the very righteousness of his son, Jesus.
That's already true of you.
That's your position.
But here's the progression.
At the same time, you are also called to be sanctified, to live a holy life.
And that is a progressive and ongoing thing.
It's the fruit of Christ's righteousness being born in your life.
And so that happens over a lifetime.
And so basically you have this ongoing integration between the new self and our way of lives,
the way of life that corresponds with that new self.
But there's wonderful news.
And here's the wonderful news is that the master sculptor is the one who is bringing this about.
Let me remind you what we saw in Ephesians chapter 2 and verse 10 where it says that we are created
in Christ Jesus for good works.
But before that, here's what it said.
It says we are his workmanship created in Christ Jesus for good works.
In other words, we are God's craftsmanship.
That's the word that's used there.
And he's created us in Christ Jesus and he's created us for the good works that
follow.
So it's God's work in our lives.
And even in verse 30 of our text this morning, we see that the Spirit of God is present in
the life of every believer.
He's like a seal, like a stamp or a brand showing that we belong to God.
So the presence and work of the Holy Spirit in the life of every believer shows that we
truly belong to the Lord.
And you might ask, well, what is God's Spirit doing in our life?
What's he doing in our midst here this morning?
Several things.
One is shaping us into the likeness of Jesus in practice.
He's drawing out that likeness.
All right.
So here's where the sculptor metaphor breaks down.
So we won't be returning to it too much because a sculpture is very passive when it comes
to being sculpted, right?
The sculpture doesn't do anything.
It just sits there as it's being chipped away at.
But that's not the case with our growth in Christ's likeness.
So Paul doesn't say here, okay, Ephesians, believers.
Let go and let God.
What he says is, here's the hammer.
Here's the chisel.
Get to work by the power of the Spirit who is at work in you.
Work out what God has worked in so that we are active participants in the process of
our growth in Christ's likeness.
So there's certain things we must learn to say no to and certain things we must
learn to say yes to.
And here in this particular text we're looking at this morning, we see that Paul doesn't just
address this in the abstract.
He gets specific here.
He deals with the concrete realities of everyday life.
And so instead of just looking at the big picture of the sculpture, if you will, he
then now takes us closer and he says, now here, look, this is what the mouth is to
look like.
If you look a bit closer at the hands, like this is what the hands should look
like here.
We list out several areas of life and we're going to look through those this morning.
There's kind of bullet points that are here.
You just, we're just going to go through the list together.
But before we go through the list, just a couple of things to keep your eye out
for.
One of them is the fact that there's a negative and a corresponding positive right
the way through in the list.
So there's things to put off and things to put on.
So holiness isn't just about saying no.
It's also about saying yes.
And also another thing with what we see in this list is that all of these things
in the list are both individual and relational as well.
So these are things that we should be working on ourselves, but we don't just do them in
order to better ourselves or to become better versions of ourselves.
We work on these areas of our lives with the good of others in view.
And so that's why Paul then starts the next chapter with walk in love.
These are relational things that we are doing so that we are a blessing to one
another.
Another final thing is just to notice that these are theological qualities as well.
The positive qualities that are put before us always remember they are the likeness
of God.
It's the likeness of Christ we're looking at.
So even as we look at these virtues, we are looking at characteristics of Jesus
himself.
Okay.
So let's go through them.
The first thing we read being spoken of here in verse 25 is lying and truthfulness.
So you see the negative and the positive.
Therefore, having put away all falsehood, let each of you speak the truth with his neighbor,
for we are members of one another.
It's been said for years that a lie can travel halfway around the world while the truth
is still putting on its shoes.
We live in a world where that is more the case than ever.
Things that are misleading or downright false can be published and disseminated and
can literally travel the globe in a matter of seconds or minutes.
But followers of Christ are to be characterized by their commitment to the truth.
So we're not given over to either spreading or saying things that are false or exaggerated
or misleading, or to be characterized by honesty.
So if we're being shaped into the likeness of God, if we have been united to Christ,
remember that this God we've been united to through him is the God who Jeremiah 1010 is true.
This is an attribute of God.
He is true.
Titus 1, 2 puts it negatively.
He is the God who never lies.
Of course, Jesus himself is the living embodiment of the truth.
One of the most famous verses in the Bible, John 14.6, I am the way, the truth and the life.
But here, Paul is particularly, I think, picking up on the language of Zechariah 8 in the Old Testament,
where Paul, or rather God, is talking there about how he is going to dwell with his people in his city
and their way of life together in that city is to be characterized by speaking the truth to one another.
It's the same language that Paul is using here.
So if we're going to be growing in Christ's likeness, it should be characterized by truth,
because he is true.
But another reason here is given is because we are members of one another.
Right? So we are part of his body, the church.
So we need to know how vital it is that we are honest with one another.
The early church father, John Chrysostom, preached on this passage and he gave a very striking illustration.
I'm going to paraphrase it here.
But he talked about how, if, say, the eye sees a snake, you're walking down a trail like some of us were yesterday,
and you see a snake on the trail, the eye's job is to speak honestly to the foot, right?
So if the eye is honest, then the foot will move away from the snake.
It won't step onto it.
But the eye could lie to the foot and so actually know that that's just a stick.
And of course, that will cause harm not only to the foot, but could cause harm to the rest of the body
and even the eye itself, right?
So if the members of the body are to be working together, they must work together,
honestly is the picture that is here.
So the body can only be healthy and work together if it's doing so in truth.
So lying is detrimental not only to us but to others within the body of Christ.
I like what John Stott said about fellowship.
He said, fellowship is built on trust and trust is built on truth.
So falsehood undermines fellowship while truth strengthens it.
So instead of coming to church to make a good impression while keeping our true selves hidden,
so to speak, let's be radically committed to honesty.
By God's grace, let's aim to be real that we might experience real change together.
And that is experienced in the context of God's love for us, but we'll see that here in a little bit.
So that's falsehood and honesty, okay?
So secondly, we see things like anger being dealt with, but also the flip side of kindness and forgiveness.
So we'll look at a couple of places, but notice in verse 26,
what it says. It says, be angry and do not sin. Do not let the sun go down on your anger
and give no opportunity to the devil. Maybe you read those first two words, be angry and thought,
yes, I've nailed it. I've got that one down. But just keep breathing on. So be angry and do not
sin, right? So what is he saying here? All right? So let's just acknowledge there is
something called righteous anger. That's how we can say be angry and do not sin.
There's such a thing as righteous indignation, right? So read the Gospels. You see Jesus getting
angry on more than one occasion. All right? There are occasions when anger is justified.
For example, Christians should not be indifferent to the evil and injustice we see in the world.
And there's times when anger is an appropriate response when, I don't know, when
children are being mistreated. You just think of a million different things that go on
that should cause a sense of righteous indignation. But anger, even anger that is initially for the
right reasons, is dangerous. If we're not careful, it can even give an opportunity for the devil to
wreak havoc in our lives and in our relationships and bring about division. So we're called to
put away righteous anger, to be angry but do not sin. So what is sinful anger then? When
does it become sinful? Well, a few things. One is when it's self-centered, certainly that.
So instead of living, say consciously under the reign of Christ, I want to be in control and I want,
there's certain things that I want and that I'm going to get whenever I don't get what I want,
I can then react in anger towards whoever or whatever it is that has gotten in the way of
me getting what I want. So unrighteous anger kind of reveals what is truly reigning over
my heart. Is it Christ? So I'm responding to him in what's happening or is it myself? And then I'm
reacting in anger towards those who get in the way of what I'm wanting. All right, so self-centered.
Another characteristic of ungodly or unrighteous anger is that it is unrestrained. So God is
slow to anger we read about in Scripture and so should we be. So James chapter one in verse 19 says,
Know this, my beloved brothers, let every person be quick to hear, slow to speak, and slow to anger.
Or Proverbs chapter 16 in verse 32 says, Whoever is slow to anger is better than the mighty
and he who rules his spirit than he who takes a city. So anger must always be restrained. It should
never be unrestrained or out of control. We should never allow anger to take the wheel and control
how we react to a situation with God's help. When we feel the anger rise up, we must learn
by his grace to pause, to give ourselves over to him, to seek his help, to respond with
restraint. Another way it should be restrained is by setting a time limit on it. That's just what it says
here. So do not let the sun go down on your anger. Psalm 103 verse 9, which we read at the start
of the service talks about how God does not keep his anger forever. So anger is something we all
feel from time to time, but our grievances must not be held on to and ruminated over where we then
look for justifications as why we feel we have the right to be mad where we're kind of adding fuel to
the fire. It's only going to get worse. And in relationships we're to, if we have acted out
of anger in terms of letting the sun go down on our wrath, we should make that right with those
that we have acted out in anger towards. But notice, before we move on to the kind of positive
equivalents, notice the progression that is here as well. If you skip down with me to verse 31,
we see there what happens when we hold on to anger and we do let the sun go down on it.
It doesn't get better, bitter, sorry, it doesn't get better. It does get bitter here. So verse
31 says, let all bitterness, bitterness can develop. We can develop a sour disposition or
distaste for those who have done us wrong. In other words, we can silently start to resent others
that we have been angry towards. It moves on to talk about wrath and anger as mentioned once again.
And these two words have a slight difference. Wrath is more of the kind of outburst that
can take place all of a sudden, whereas anger here is more of like a settled hostility that is there
underneath the surface brewing. Then talks about putting away clamor and slander. Clamor is more like
fighting with each other. So like a shouting match with someone. That's the idea of clamor here.
And then slander is then how you are then speaking about that person to others,
demeaning them, aiming to tarnish their reputation. And then notice that it then says to the word to put
away all malice as well. And malice is kind of hoping what that others get kind of what they have
coming to them anyway, so to speak. It's maybe even plotting to bring that about
with their own demise. So you see that progression of the way you're continually looking,
how you're feeling, the outbursts, and then the spreading things and looking for their demise.
So none of that reflects the mercy that we have been shown in Jesus. In vengeance doesn't belong
to us, it belongs to the Lord. So anger must be something that we repent over when it's unrestrained
and unrighteous. What are we to put on in the flip side? What are we to be seeking
the Lord for? What speaks of kindness? We're instead to put on kindness. The Greek word for kindness here
is a Christos, and it's almost identical to the word Christos, the word for Christ. It's almost a
play on words here, kindness and Christ. So if we're going to be like Christ, then our lives
should be characterized by the kindness that God shows us in him. Tenderhearted, instead of
looking on others with sourness and resent, we do so with the compassion of Christ. That's the
tenderheartedness that is there. And then notice it also speaks about forgiveness. So verse 32,
be kind to one another, tenderhearted, forgiving one another, as God in Christ has forgiven you.
So sometimes anger can rise up, not just because we didn't get our own way in a purely selfish
sense, but because we've legitimately been wronged. Someone sends against us and it hurts,
but instead of holding on to that in anger, we're being called here to give it over to the Lord and
to let go of it. That's what forgiveness is, letting go, giving that over to the Lord and
forgiving others. So how can we do that? Why should we do that? What tells us
forgiving one another as God in Christ forgave you? That's why, because of the gospel. So the pathway
that leads to becoming a more forgiving person is realizing just how much God has forgiven us
in Christ. It's seeking his help to forgive as we have been forgiven by him. So we're knowing
his own forgiveness for our sinfulness, even our anger. And asking for his help to offer that to
others who have done us wrong. So Jesus once told a story of a man in Matthew 18,
and there was a parable about a guy who owed in the equivalent today like billions of dollars to
somebody. And then he was then forgiven his debt so he no longer owes the billions of dollars.
And you would think that would sort of teach him a lesson where if I've been forgiven that much,
I should forgive others. But instead he goes out and he finds a servant of his who owes him just
a few dollars by comparison. And he assaults that servant. And he has him thrown in prison
because of the debt that he owes. So Jesus is giving us a picture there. And it's
when we realize how much we have been forgiven by God, it should lead us to treat others
with forgiveness because it's so small by comparison. All of us have sinned against a holy God and
deserve his wrath. The debt is bigger than we could ever pay. And yet Jesus was willing to
pay our debt on the cross to receive the judgment that we were due. That's how big the debt is.
So big that it cost the son of God his life. But he paid it. So if he did that for you,
how could you hold something against someone else? May the Lord help us to forgive others as we've been
forgiven. Third, notice it then moves on to talk about theft and the flip side work and generosity.
So let the thief, verse 28, no longer steal, but rather let him labor doing honest work with
his own hands so that he may have something to share with anyone in need.
So in 1859 there was a revival that took place in Northern Ireland. And one of the evidences of
the genuineness of that revival that took place there was how people started returning stolen goods.
People were convicted of their sin. And it wasn't just a kind of an emotional meeting
where everybody felt really good, felt a sense of God's presence and worship. The repentance could
actually be seen in the restoration that happened. And people started bringing stolen goods so much
so that a warehouse had to be cleared out and dedicated. So this is the warehouse for stolen
goods. And you can read about how piles and piles of stolen tools and things like that were
being brought to this warehouse. So what we see in the story of Zacchaeus, isn't it? Luke chapter
19, how do we know that Christ changed his life? He said, well, everything I've taken, I'm going to
repay, and I'm going to even give more on top of that. So that's where you see the genuineness of
his repentance. So one of the evidences that we have the new life of Christ dwelling within us
is that we stop stealing. We take up honest work and give to others. So throughout the book of
Ephesians, we've seen that God not only withholds his anger in mercy, but he also gives out of the
abundance of his grace. And so when he transforms us, he makes us into giving people instead of those
who would be taking people. So theft is the opposite of giving graciously. It takes from others. It
uses others for what they can get out of them. It can even take the form of like not doing the
work that you are paid for kind of being on the clock, but I'm actually giving yourself to the work
that is in front of you. Once again, the old self is at the center of that. What does the new self do
that's so different? Well, it takes on honest work. Can I just say as a kind of slight aside to
that, isn't it? Isn't it wonderful to see that the life of Christ dwelling within you doesn't
just seem in like the singing of hymns. Like the life of Christ being formed in you is seen in
the swinging of a hammer or the balancing of a budget. It's seen in honest work as you're knowing
the Lord's presence and help in the work that he has given you to do. We were made to work and God
uses our work to accomplish his good purposes in the world. And so our work should be done for
his glory and with the good of others in view. It reflects the grace that we have been shown.
So it's not there. Our work isn't there so that we can kind of fulfill our own personal ambitions
or that so we can have a higher standard of living. Now, don't hear me wrong, but we are free to enjoy
the fruit of our labor and to give God thanks for that. But don't forget that one of the main
reasons we are called to work is so that we can be enabled to be generous to others
with what the Lord has given us to reflection of grace. That should be our motivating factor,
the glory of God and the good of others. All right, the last thing in the list here is
tearing down and building up with our words. All right, so tearing down with our words,
building up with our words. Verse 29, let no corrupting talk come out of your mouths,
but only such is as good for building up as fits the occasion that it may give grace to those who
hear. So our words are to be constructive rather than destructive. They are to build others up
rather than tearing them down. This is a theme right through right the way throughout Scripture,
the power of words. So Proverbs 18 21 says death and life are in the power of the tongue.
So our words can be hurtful. I don't know if any of you have been seeing, I'm sure all of us have,
the fires that have taken place in Los Angeles and all the destruction that is there and
these wildfires, it doesn't have to start off as a big fire to become a huge devastating fire.
It can start off as something so small. And that's the case with our words.
Scripture actually uses that illustration saying that our tongue can be like a small fire that
can cause a lot of damage and pain. So saying things that are say vulgar or unkind doesn't help anyone,
but they do hurt. And our words should fit the occasion, what we say matters, but also
when we say it and how we say it matters as well. I know there could be a tendency,
particularly in this kind of cultural moment, to say, well, I'm just the sort of person who
tells it like it is. Like I'm a truth teller, but our words must fit the occasion, right? So
being the sort of person who tells it like it is isn't an excuse for being unkind and unthoughtful
in how you say something and when you say it. So we're to be people who are building others
up rather than tearing them down with our words. It's interesting Paul brings up here
grieving the Holy Spirit. So what grieves the Holy Spirit? Well, it's just to think the Holy Spirit
is a person. Something grieves him. So what is it? Well, surely it's unholiness. There's a specific
unholiness that's just been spoken about. That's unholiness in the context of how we speak to
one another. So if we are the body of Christ animated by the Holy Spirit of God, then our
words don't just cause grief to one another, but the very Spirit of God dwelling within us
is grieved when we tear one another down with our words. But the same tongue that tears down
does also build up. I mean, think of ways words can build up. I mean, think of the power of the
gospel being shared. You can share the truth of the gospel and somebody can be raised from death
to life. That's the power of words in the hands of the Spirit of God. Also the power of
sharing that truth with one another continually or reminding one another of the promises of God or
calling attention to specific ways we can see the grace of God at work in one another. Like,
here's how I see the likeness of Christ coming out in you. We can encourage one another with
our words. We can tell one another how much people are appreciated or loved. Our words are a channel of
God's grace to those who hear. One of the ways that God is gracious to his people is through the
words that we speak to one another. Think of it. Okay, so we've had this list. So Paul,
having given these examples, then steps back again from the detail of the sculpture back to
the whole thing. And he reminds us of the big picture by saying, therefore, be imitators of God
as beloved children and walk in love as Christ loved us and gave himself up for us a fragrant
offering and sacrifice to God. Okay, so he's essentially saying what he already said earlier
in the book were to be imitators of God, living lives that are patterned after Christ.
And him we see the likeness of God. We've already seen that. But notice that it's built around the
love of God specifically here. So that's the thought I want to leave us with here. The kind of title
for the message today from here is just the words walk in love, because that's how Paul summarizes
here. So it's knowing the love of God that shapes us in this lifelong process of change. So we
change when two things happen. One, when we are secure in the love of God, secure in his love. So
we're to be imitators of God as beloved children. So children learn to speak and to walk and to do
other things that aren't so great by imitating their parents. Like I dread to think of what's
being said by children in Sunday school like revealing what's happened at home or whatever.
So we imitate, but it says imitate as not just as children, but as beloved children.
So here's the context of change knowing that I am loved by God. So we don't try to do the
right thing. We don't try to change ourselves in order to become God's children. But because we
are, we know we're loved. So we don't put away things and put on things that we might be
loved or more loved by him, but because we know that we are loved by him. So we rest secure knowing
that we are God's beloved children. That doesn't come by our own perfection. You know, if you were
honest with yourself as you look through the list, as I've been doing all week, you can see like,
oh, there's things that need to change here in me. And so you look at that and say, well,
am I really loved? What's not by looking within that we know whether or not we are loved,
it's by looking out to Christ and seeing God's love demonstrated for us in him,
particularly in his death on the cross. It's in him that you know how much you are loved. And if
you know that you are that loved, that you won't hide away in the shadows with those things that
need to be changed. Instead, you'll bring them out into the light, the light of the one who loves
you, that he might help you in that process of change. So it's in the context of God's love,
but also the second thing is that we are being shaped by the love of Christ. So we're secure in
his love, we're being shaped by that love. So he tells us here, walk in love. By the way, the kids
in the back, I think that we're looking at the 10 commandments today. And if you were to
summarize the 10 commandments in four words, it'd be love God, love others, right? That's
the summary there. So we're to walk in love. Where do we see that love? In Christ, as Christ loved us.
So the call to walk in love is a call to show others the love that we have been shown, that we have
come to know in Jesus. And we can't save anybody that belongs to Christ's sacrifice alone,
but we can love others by laying down our lives for their good, laying down our preferences
for their good. And this is a sacrifice. You see what it says here, as Christ loved us and gave
himself for us a fragrant offering and sacrifice to God. So when we lay down our lives, it isn't
just for the good of others, it is an act of worship to God. And when we do that, when we
love one another as we're called to, as we've been loved by Christ, that goes up as a, as a
fragrant offering, it's a pleasing smell. God is pleased to accept our worship. So we lay down
our lives because Jesus is worth it. He is worthy. In him we know and experience true love
and the pleasure of God. And it's out of that that we care for one another. So let's walk in
love. So we're going to come now to a time of communion together. And communion is given to us
as a reminder of this love that we have been shown in Jesus. It shows us the love that we are secure
in, the love that shapes us into the people we were made to be. The broken bread reminds us of
the body of Christ broken for us. The wine reminds us of his blood shed for us. And all of
this was done in love. So we thought about specific areas of sin and righteousness this morning.
We're coming to this table remembering that Jesus has paid for our sins. So before we come,
I want us all to pause and to pray, to think about what the Lord may have laid his finger on
in you, but also to remember Christ's death for you on the cross. So let's take this moment
to repent and to put our trust in Jesus and to know his love for us. Then I'll pray
and we'll come to this table.
Okay.
God, in this your love was demonstrated in that while we were still sinners,
Christ died for us.
So Lord, in the light of your holiness, we do see our sin and those areas that need to change.
Well, Lord, we thank you that you do not deal with us according to those sins, but in Jesus,
you have shown us mercy and grace. Or do you have shown us your love? So Lord, as we come to
this table, Lord, I pray that we would come humbly knowing just how much we have been forgiven.
Lord, I pray that we would come gratefully as well knowing just how much we have been
loved. Lord, I pray that we would come to your table knowing that you are our loving,
heavenly Father and that you have shown your great love for us in Jesus. So I pray that
we would know your presence and help as we come and worship now. In Jesus' name, amen.